san diego paradis des surfeurs des
amoureux des plages et du farniente mais
dans ce décor de rêve californien autant
sur les plages dans les parcs magnifique
dans les lieux touristiques et bien sûr
dans bien des quartiers de la ville et
du centre de san diego les sans abri se
comptent par milliers
pour se rendre compte de la situation de
plus en plus critique nous suivons
l'équipe de christian denis une
infirmière qui sillonnent la ville à la
rencontre des sans logis dans certains
quartiers leur nombre a presque doublé
depuis deux ans
les causes sont malheureusement commune
à toutes les grandes villes
parmi les sans abri qu'elles rencontrent
les histoires sont assez similaires puis
d'emplois plus de logements est bien
vite c'est la spirale du désespoir parmi
les patients du jour il ya à chi l'ha
dans la rue depuis trois mois problème
de santé mentale une santé physique
défaillante un exemple assez commun dans
le travail quotidien de kristen
et moi de continuer plus loin et le
croiser michiru un habitué
problèmes de peau manque de confiance en
lui son esprit n'est pas toujours clair
surtout quand les services sociaux
l'encouragent à se présenter à une foire
d'emploi pour essayer de le sortir de la
rue
[Musique]
go
des trousses d'hygiène des kits pour
traiter les overdoses d'opioïdes les
besoins sont très variés
les travailleurs de rue font ce qu'ils
peuvent face à cette croissance
exponentielle de pauvreté dans la rue
justement ce matin là nous rencontrons
40 ans une toxicomane qui pensent être
enceinte son besoin immédiat est assez
simple
elle souhaiterait davantage de douches
disponibles pour elle et ses semblables
le nombre des sans abri à san diego
s'approcherait dangereusement des dix
mille selon certaines estimations
pour les commerçants cela n'a rien de
réjouissant pour l'image de la ville
[Musique]
selon ce conseiller municipal la
solution passe d'abord par des
subventions pour aider ceux qui peinent
à payer leur loyer et qui sont sur le
board se retrouver dans la rue la ville
a multiplié les ouvertures de refuge
depuis deux ans et veut maintenant
implanté dcf vers hedges sorte de
rassemblement de tentes
et
on attendant le lancement éventuel de ce
projet les sans logis de san diego se
font déplacer deux fois par semaine par
la ville afin de procéder au nettoyage
des trottoirs ou la crasse et les
déchets s'accumulent la ville dit
prendre le problème à bras le corps mais
il y à de la résistance
a dit vigneault men thymine
une résistance qui vient non seulement
de la population qui ne veut pas voir de
logements sociaux près de chez elle mais
aussi de la part des sans abri
l'infirmière complète son tour de la
ville en rencontrant scott qui a quitté
l'ohio pour un pèlerinage afin de
répandre les cendres de sa femme dans
les endroits qu'ils ont tenté mais à
noël dernier il a épuisé ses ressources
et s'est retrouvé dans la rue il a quand
même eu le temps de renvoyer son fils de
19 ans en ohio
[Musique]
you can dance est vraiment nom du
cabinet
l'envers du décor du rêve californien
n'est pas reluisant mais on reste
convaincu que les projets des dos sans
abri qui sont sur la table actuellement
permettront d'y faire face mais la tâche
sera ardue